When they started to prepare for COVID-19 patients at Rogue Regional Medical Center in Southern Oregon, Dr. Somnath Ghosh was part of the team. He's the medical director for the intensive care unit, a pulmonary specialist, and very dedicated to his job. Works long hours, the kind of doctor who gives out his cell phone number to staff, and patients, and families. He tells them to use it anytime. And his wife, Renu, is also a doctor, says he really threw himself into this task.
当俄勒冈州南部的罗格地区医疗中心开始为新冠肺炎患者做准备时，Somnath Ghosh 医生是团队的一员。他是重症监护室的医学主任，也是一名肺科专家，工作非常敬业。他工作时间很长，会把自己的手机号码留给员工、病人和家属。他告诉他们随时可以打给他。他的妻子 Renu 也是一名医生，她说他真的全身心地投入到了这项工作中。
He spent a lot of his even off time at the hospital trying to gear up for the big wave to hit us.
他甚至把很多休息时间都花在医院里，为即将到来的大浪潮做准备。
Right.
没错。
And he's a little bit of a geek, so got super excited. He's like, "Oh, we today figured out how to use one ventilator on eight patients instead of-- I think four or six is considered the max standard. So he's been calculating, OK, we'll be able to vent 360 patients, preparing for all of this.
而且他有点极客精神，所以非常兴奋。他说：“哦，我们今天算出来怎么用一台呼吸机救治八名病人，而不是——我想四到六名被认为是最大标准。所以他一直在计算，好的，我们将能够为 360 名病人提供呼吸支持，为这一切做准备。
So far, they've been lucky. The pandemic has mostly spared the half million people his hospital serves in Southern Oregon. But I spoke with her husband, Dr. Ghosh, one afternoon last week. He said in total, they've only had three COVID patients that needed intensive care. Dr. Ghosh prepared for a war that he's not having to fight. But all the time, he gets invitations to go join the fight in New York, Louisiana, and other hotspots, begging him to fly out and help.
到目前为止，他们很幸运。疫情在很大程度上绕过了他所在的俄勒冈州南部医院所服务的五十万人。但是上周的一天下午，我和她的丈夫 Ghosh 医生谈了谈。他说，总共只有三名新冠患者需要重症监护。Ghosh 医生为一场他不必参与的战争做了准备。但他一直在收到邀请，要去纽约、路易斯安那州和其他热点地区加入战斗，请求他飞过去帮忙。
Every single day. In fact, I get at least four or five of these a day. And I've been getting them for the last few weeks. I can read you a few.
每天都如此。事实上，我每天至少会收到四到五个这样的请求。过去几周我一直都在收到它们。我可以给你读几条。
Sure.
当然。
"Hi, Dr. Ghosh. It's Elizabeth with Core Medical. I hope you're doing well. We have a client in New York who needs critical care support. Due to a high volume of patients, I hope to connect with you soon. Thank you, for all you do."
“你好，Ghosh 医生。我是 Core Medical 的 Elizabeth。希望你一切都好。我们在纽约有一位客户需要重症监护支持。由于病人数量庞大，希望尽快与你联系。感谢你所做的一切。”
Another one says, "Immediate ICU coverage needed. Should you be able to assist, please give me a call or send a CV to" yadda, yadda, yadda. "We can license." Another one says, "Good morning. A facility in Houston area is needing some help in their ICU. Can you help them during this crisis?"
另一条说：“急需 ICU 人手。如果你能提供帮助，请给我打电话或将简历发送到……”云云。我们可以提供执照。”另一条说：“早上好。休斯顿地区的一家医疗机构需要 ICU 方面的帮助。在这个危机时刻，你能帮帮他们吗？”
I also have received texts from friends, personally. They're in such a need for critical care physicians.
我还收到了朋友们的个人短信。他们非常需要重症监护医师。
Do you wish you can go?
你希望你能去吗？
Oh, hell yeah. Hell, yeah. I mean, this-- I mean, this is what I trained for. This is what I do. This is six years of specialty training, and then nine years of experience. I feel useless sitting here in Southern Oregon while the Northeast is getting pummeled.
哦，天哪，当然想。我是说，这——这是我受过训练要去做的事情。这就是我的工作。这是六年专业培训和九年的经验。我坐在俄勒冈州南部，而东北部正遭受重创，我感到自己毫无用处。
Yeah. Like there's a historic medical emergency that could use your exact special skills.
是的。就像有一场历史性的医疗紧急情况，正需要你这种专门的技能。
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I feel guilty even going home and playing with my kids and watching TV. And I know my friends and my brethren on the East Coast are risking their lives, suboptimal PPE, not enough specialists to help them.
是啊。我是说，我甚至为回家陪孩子玩、看电视而感到内疚。我知道我在东海岸的朋友和同僚们正冒着生命危险，在个人防护装备不足、缺乏专家帮助的情况下工作。
So he comes back from work one day. I'm in the midst of getting dinner going for our two children, and he's like, what do you think about me going to New York? I am sitting here. Nothing is happening. And there, they are just dying.
所以有一天他下班回来。我正忙着给我们两个孩子准备晚餐，他说，我去纽约怎么样？我坐在这里。什么事都没发生。而在那里，他们正在死去。
And I think my first flash action was just anger. I'm like, how can you be so selfish? You only always think as a physician. And me, or the kids, or family, just you don't even think about it. And trying to go to New York? Especially, looking for trouble? I'm like, there are other doctors, but I only have one husband. My kids have only one dad. And you're the only son to your mom, who's a widow now and kind of depends on you for everything.
我想我的第一反应只是愤怒。我在想，你怎么能这么自私？你总是只以医生的身份思考。而我，或者孩子们，或者家庭，你甚至都不考虑。还想去纽约？特别是，去自找麻烦？我想，还有其他医生，但我只有一个丈夫。我的孩子们只有一个爸爸。而你是你母亲唯一的儿子，她现在是个寡妇，几乎在各方面都依赖你。
But then I think 10 minutes later, I was telling myself that I'm not surprised by this. He's at his best when he's the physician. He works harder than anything he'll work at at home. He's more patient with his staff and patients than he is with my children. It's just how he connects. I think there's some part of him which just gets very satisfied when he's able to help someone.
但十分钟后，我告诉自己，我对此并不感到惊讶。当他作为一名医生时，他处于最佳状态。他工作起来比在家里做的任何事情都要努力。他对员工和病人比对我的孩子更有耐心。这就是他建立联系的方式。我想他内心深处有一部分，当他能够帮助别人时，会感到非常满足。
But he's not going to go to New York, and not because of her. Not because of their kids, who are still little. Not because he's worried he'll get COVID. He's young and healthy and has a doctor's overconfidence, assuming he's going to be fine. He's not going to save lives like he wants, because he can't go. And he can't go because of his immigration status. He's in the United States on something called an H1B visa.
但他不会去纽约，不是因为她。不是因为他们还在年幼的孩子。不是因为他担心会感染新冠。他年轻健康，有着医生那种过度自信，以为自己会没事的。他无法像他想的那样去拯救生命，因为他不能去。而他不能去是因为他的移民身份。他在美国持有一种叫做 H1B 的签证。
And the rules prohibit me from working for anyone else other than my employer.
而且规定禁止我为雇主以外的任何人工作。
So he has to stay in Oregon. He can't go to work for a hospital in Brooklyn or New Orleans. He can't even volunteer.
所以他必须留在俄勒冈州。他不能去布鲁克林或新奥尔良的医院工作。他甚至不能做志愿者。
We're in a health emergency in the United States. And over a fourth of the physicians here are foreign born. Over 8,000 of those have the kind of visa that Somnath has, an H1B visa, which is given to people who have special education or skills and want to work in the United States.
美国正处于卫生紧急状态。而这里超过四分之一的医生是外国出生的。其中超过 8,000 人拥有像 Somnath 那样的签证，即 H1B 签证，这是发给那些拥有特殊教育或技能并希望在美国工作的人的。
In Somnath's case, he was born in India, came here for his medical residency, got his H1B visa when he got his first job out of training at the hospital where he still works nine years later. If he had a green card, it would fix the problem. And he's waiting for one, but the backlog on green cards is massive. That'll take decades.
就 Somnath 而言，他出生在印度，来这里完成了医学住院医师实习，在九年前从培训毕业后的第一份工作时就拿到了 H1B 签证，至今仍在同一家医院工作。如果他有绿卡，问题就解决了。他正在等待绿卡，但绿卡的积压非常严重。那需要几十年。
He believes the government should grant exceptions to the rules right now and let health workers with H1B visas fly to the hotspots and help out during this crisis. And dozens of senators and Congress people, mostly Democrats, but a few Republicans sprinkled in, have tried to get the US Citizenship and Immigration Service to do just that, though that hasn't gotten much traction.
他认为政府现在应该对规则给予豁免，让持有 H1B 签证的医护人员飞往热点地区，在危机期间提供帮助。数十名参议员和国会议员，主要是民主党人，也有少数共和党人，试图让美国公民及移民服务局这样做，但这并没有得到太多的推动。
So Dr. Ghosh is stuck in Southern Oregon during this crisis, far from the action.
所以 Ghosh 医生在这次危机期间被困在俄勒冈州南部，远离一线。
What if you just went? Couldn't you just go?
如果你直接过去会怎么样？你就不能直接去吗？
Well, if I do that, then I violate the terms of my H1B, and it becomes null and void.
嗯，如果我那样做，我就违反了 H1B 的条款，它将变得无效。
Oh, I see. Then you'd be here illegally, all of a sudden.
哦，我明白了。那么你突然就会成为非法滞留了。
Well, yeah. Then I'll be out of status, which means I'll be unemployed. And yeah, that thought did cross my mind. Trust me.
嗯，是的。那么我就失去了身份，这意味着我将失业。是的，那个想法确实闪过我的脑海。相信我。
But the cost is just too high.
但代价太高了。
Yeah. If I was just by myself, sure. I'd do what I thought was right, and then I could just up and leave, go back to India or elsewhere. With a wife and a 3-year-old and a six-year-old, yeah, I can't risk that.
是的。如果只是我一个人，当然。我会做我认为正确的事，然后我可以直接起身离开，回印度或其他地方。有了妻子和一个 3 岁、一个 6 岁的孩子，是的，我冒不起这个险。
Yeah. How does it make you feel that you can't help?
是的。无法提供帮助让你有什么感觉？
Frustrated. Small. I mean, you'd think that common sense will prevail and they'd do what's right for the population, especially in such trying times. You want to yell and shout and scream and say, what exactly are you guys thinking of?
沮丧。渺小。我的意思是，你本以为常识会占上风，他们会为民众做正确的事，尤其是在这种困难时期。你想大喊大叫，质问他们到底在想什么？
Dr. Ghosh says before this, he felt happy in Southern Oregon. He's one of the leaders in his hospital. He felt like he belonged. But since COVID, for the first time he's started to think he might leave the United States.
Ghosh 医生说在此之前，他在俄勒冈州南部感到很幸福。他是医院的领导之一。他觉得他属于这里。但自从新冠疫情以来，他第一次开始考虑离开美国。
I've been thinking about this more and more, because my kids are only 3 and 6. They can easily adapt to a new way of life.
我一直在思考这个问题，因为我的孩子才 3 岁和 6 岁。他们可以很容易地适应新的生活方式。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
I'll be honest. The community in Southern Oregon has embraced me, and this is home for me. I was happy just doing my job, raising my family. And then when this thing hit and I realized how helpless I am and how inconsequential, it boggles my mind that they don't think that this is a priority. If this happens again this winter with an outbreak and this repeats itself, I'm out of here. I'm done.
老实说。俄勒冈州南部的社区接纳了我，这里是我的家。我很高兴能做好我的工作，抚养我的家庭。然后当这件事发生时，我意识到自己是多么无助和无关紧要，他们不认为这是优先事项，这让我感到震惊。如果今年冬天再发生一次爆发，这种情况再次重演，我就离开这里。我受够了。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Oh, like if this winter season there's another surge and then we're hit with the flu, and the coronavirus, and a personnel and equipment shortage, and they need help, I'm not going to sit around just going through this rigmarole all over again. I'm going to pack my bags and leave. Maybe make a stop in New York or something for a few weeks before I leave.
哦，比如如果这个冬季又有一次浪潮，然后我们同时受到流感和冠状病毒的冲击，再加上人员和设备短缺，他们需要帮助，我不会坐视这一切再次发生。我会收拾行李离开。也许在离开前在纽约停留几周什么的。
So the plan would be to leave, take the whole family back to India. And maybe on the way, you'd work for a few weeks or months in a New York hospital, since at that point it wouldn't matter.
所以计划是离开，把全家带回印度。也许在路上，你会去纽约的一家医院工作几周或几个月，因为到那时这已经无所谓了。
Might as well. I mean, if I'm going to get out of here, I might as well do some good along the way.
最好还是去吧。我的意思是，如果我要离开这里，我不如在路上做点好事。
When I asked his wife, Renu, about that plan, she was like, well, we'll decide about that together. For now anyway, Somnath is stuck, getting texts like this one that he got recently from a friend, a guy who he went to medical school with, who's now in New Jersey, deluged with COVID cases.
当我问他的妻子 Renu 关于那个计划时，她说，好吧，我们会一起决定这件事。无论如何，现在 Somnath 被困住了，收到像他最近从一位朋友那里收到的这样的短信，那是他医学院的同学，现在在新泽西州，被新冠病例淹没了。
So here he says, "Hey, dude, haven't heard back from you in a few days. What happened to your plans of coming here? We could certainly use you. Getting our asses kicked here. Besides, I haven't seen you forever."
这里他写道：“嘿，伙计，几天没听到你的回信了。你来这里的计划怎么了？我们肯定用得着你。我们在这里被搞得团团转。再说，我已经很久没见到你了。”
So I reply, "So apparently cannot help, due to H1B visa." So he replies, "Are you f-ing kidding me? We are using residents from unrelated specialties in our ICU. You're just going to sit there?"
所以我回复：“看来因为 H1B 签证，无法提供帮助。”他回复说：“你在开什么国际玩笑？我们都在 ICU 里使用来自非相关专业的住院医师了。你就打算坐在那里吗？”
So I reply, "What do you want me to do?" And he's like, "This is bullshit, bro. I gotta go. Talk to you later."
所以我回复：“你想让我怎么做？”他说：“这真是胡扯，兄弟。我得走了。回头聊。”
Later in our program, Stuck. There's so many of us stuck at home, or stuck without a job, or stuck on hold for everything next that was going to happen in our lives, waiting for a future to arrive that now seems unreadable and impenetrable.
节目稍后，困境。我们中有这么多人被困在家里，或被困在没有工作的地方，或被困在等待生活中发生的下一件事，等待着一个现在看起来难以解读和难以逾越的未来。
We have stories of people stuck in some unusual and extreme situations with-- I swear, we are human beings here at our show, we need this, too-- with some happy endings in some stories. From WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们有一些人被困在不同寻常和极端情况下的故事——我发誓，我们节目里的人也是有血有肉的，我们也需要这个——有些故事有圆满的结局。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, You Can Check Out Anytime You Like, But You Can Never Leave. So our show today is about people who are stuck. And years ago, one of our co-workers, Elna Baker, found herself trapped in a hotel room with her siblings, held there by a stranger.
第一幕，你可以随时结账，但你永远无法离开。所以我们今天的节目是关于被困住的人。多年前，我们的同事 Elna Baker 发现自己和兄弟姐妹被困在酒店房间里，被一个陌生人挟持。
What happened was, their family was all staying at this Marriott. But they're such a big family, four of the kids were in one room, with the oldest kid and the parents next door. Elna was 14 years old at the time, in the room with 10-year-old Julia, 8-year-old Britain, and 5-year-old Jill, who Elna was sharing a bed with. Elna, the 14-year-old, the eighth grader, was more or less in charge.
事情是这样的，他们的家人都住在万豪酒店。但他们是一个大家庭，四个孩子住一间房，大一点的孩子和父母住在隔壁。Elna 当时 14 岁，和 10 岁的 Julia、8 岁的 Britain 以及 5 岁的 Jill 住在同一个房间，Elna 和 Jill 同床。14 岁的 Elna，八年级的学生，或多或少负责照顾她们。
And then one night they're all asleep, it's the middle of the night.
有一天晚上他们都睡着了，正是午夜。
My memory is that it's like I saw like a sliver of light, which is what woke me up, and the sound of the door closing. And there was the feeling that there was someone standing at the foot of the bed.
我的记忆是，我看到了像一丝光亮，那是把我惊醒的东西，还有门关上的声音。有一种感觉，床尾站着一个人。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
So I reached over, and I turned the lamp on. And there was this woman.
所以我伸手打开了灯。有一个女人在那里。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And she looked startled to see us. And the first thing she said was, you're just children. I didn't expect you to be children.
她看到我们时显得很吃惊。她说的第一句话是，你们只是孩子。我没想到你们会是孩子。
So that's pretty creepy.
这挺令人毛骨悚然的。
Right.
对。
What did you make of her saying that?
你认为她那么说是什么意思？
I instantly felt like this is an unsafe situation.
我立刻感觉到这是一种不安全的情况。
Yeah. Describe her.
是啊。描述一下她。
I remember she was my mom's age, so she was probably in her 40s.
我记得她和我妈妈年纪差不多，所以她可能 40 多岁。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
And brown hair, white, frumpy looking, like somebody you'd sit next to on the bus or something.
棕色头发，白人，看起来邋邋遢遢的，就像你在公交车上旁边会坐的那种人。
Did she seem menacing?
她看起来有威胁性吗？
She seemed really distressed. She was crying, too.
她看起来真的很痛苦。她也在哭。
She was crying?
她在哭？
She was crying, yep. She cried the whole time she was there.
她在哭，是的。她在那里的时候一直在哭。
She's crying, and she said, "You're children. I didn't expect you to be children."
她在哭，她说：“你们是孩子。我没想到你们会是孩子。”
Yeah.
是啊。
And did the other kids get up?
其他孩子起来了吗？
Everyone's wide awake. I distinctly remember my little brothers' and sisters faces, because their eyes were just huge. But no one said anything.
所有人都醒着。我清楚地记得我弟弟妹妹们的脸，因为他们的眼睛睁得大大的。但没人说话。
And are they sitting up, too? Or are they just laying flat still?
他们也坐起来了吗？还是只是平躺着不动？
They're still laying flat. Like, nobody moved.
他们仍然平躺着。就像，没人动。
So what happens next?
那么接下来发生了什么？
She's talking, right? This isn't how it was supposed to be. And she's also crying. And she's talking to herself. I remember it being very hard to follow what she was saying.
她在说话，对吧？事情本不该是这样的。她也在哭。她在自言自语。我记得很难听懂她在说什么。
Yeah.
是啊。
And eventually I said, I'm sorry. I think you have the wrong room. And she started to cry, and she said, I know, I know. I do this, I do this. I don't know why I do this. And then she's pacing back and forth and crying. And she sits down on the bed, at the foot of the bed.
最终我说，对不起。我想你走错房间了。她开始哭，她说，我知道，我知道。我做了这种事，我做了这事。我不知道我为什么要这么做。然后她在来回踱步和哭泣。她在床尾坐了下来。
Did she seem crazy? Or did she seem upset?
她看起来疯了吗？还是看起来很心烦？
I mean, it's interesting. I think I-- I was too young and unfamiliar to identify what a crazy person seems like.
嗯，这很有趣。我想我——我当时太年轻，不熟悉疯子看起来是什么样的。
Yeah.
是啊。
But what I could identify in that moment was that this person was unpredictable.
但我能在那一刻识别出的是，这个人是不可预测的。
So you were just like, oh, I've got to be really careful how I do this.
所以你只是想，哦，我得非常小心我怎么做。
I remember feeling that pressure and, in that moment, very, very, very aware of my brothers and sisters, because they were so little.
我记得感到那种压力，那一刻，非常非常非常关注我的弟弟妹妹们，因为他们太小了。
Yeah.
是啊。
And that something bad could happen to them. And that the way that it wasn't going to happen to them was me. There were no adults there. I think it was the first situation I was ever in where there was-- you couldn't defer to someone else to keep you safe or tell you what to do. And what do I do?
而且他们可能会发生坏事。而防止他们发生那种事的方法就是我。那里没有成年人。我认为这是我曾经经历过的第一个情况，在那里没有——你不能指望别人来保证你的安全或告诉你该怎么做。我该怎么办？
And it had that quality of like, time slows down. And you're there, but you're also watching. And so then I did the math in my head, and I was like, OK, I have a couple options. They are cry for help, scream, but I don't think anyone will hear.
那种感觉就像时间变慢了。你身处其中，但你也在观察。所以在心里做了一个计算，我想，好的，我有几个选择。它们是呼救、尖叫，但我认为没人会听到。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
I remember looking at how far away the phone was from me, and I realized I can reach and grab the phone, and I could call for help. Or even like if I could knock on the door where my sister was--
我记得看了看电话离我有多远，我意识到我可以伸手去拿电话，我可以求救。或者即使我可以敲响我姐妹隔壁连接门的门——
Sister in the connecting room next door.
姐妹在隔壁连接房间。
I could-- at least they would know something was happening in here, and they could get to us in time.
我可以——至少他们会知道这里发生了一些事，他们能及时赶来帮我们。
Yeah.
是啊。
But all of that felt like an escalation, like I would provoke her. And so what can I do to not provoke her and play up the fact that we're children? And what I felt I needed to do was I needed to calm her down and become her friend. And if I could become her friend, she would leave, and she wouldn't hurt us.
但所有这些都感觉像是升级，好像会激怒她。所以为了不激怒她，发挥我们是孩子这一事实，我能做什么呢？我觉得我需要做的是让她平静下来，成为她的朋友。如果我能成为她的朋友，她就会离开，她就不会伤害我们。
Like, get her to see you as a person.
就像，让她把你当成一个人看。
It was like, make her think I was on her side. Because then it didn't feel like she didn't see us as people. It just felt dangerous, and I didn't understand why. And I felt like the key to being safe was slowing everything down.
就像是，让她以为我站在她这一边。因为那样就不觉得她没把我们当人看。只是觉得很危险，我不明白为什么。我觉得安全的关键是让一切慢下来。
And I remember her saying, I'm really sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry I'm here. I'm sorry I'm doing this. I'm sorry.
我记得她说，我真的很抱歉。对不起。我很抱歉我在这里。对不起我做了这件事。对不起。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
And I don't remember this, but my brother remembers that what she said was, I'm sorry, girls. I'm sorry, girls. And that his whole memory of this night was just being like, I'm a boy.
我不记得了，但我哥哥记得她说的是，对不起，女孩们。对不起，女孩们。他那天晚上的全部记忆就是像，我是个男孩。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He was so mad.
他当时非常生气。
And so I ask her. I said, are you OK? Is everything OK? And she kept going on about how her night was so hard. And I was like, I'm so sorry. That sounds really, really difficult.
所以我问她。我说，你还好吗？一切都还好吗？她一直喋喋不休地说她的夜晚有多么困难。我说，我很抱歉。听起来真的很艰难。
And this is you trying to befriend her?
这是你试图和她交朋友？
Yeah, this is me trying to befriend her. But it's weird. I feel like I was hyper alert to, if I can understand what's going on with her, I can help solve it. But I couldn't understand, because it didn't make any sense.
是的，这是我试图和她交朋友。但这很奇怪。我觉得我高度警觉，如果我能理解她身上发生了什么，我就能帮忙解决。但我无法理解，因为它一点也不合理。
Did you feel sorry for her?
你为她感到难过吗？
I felt concerned for her.
我为她感到担忧。
Yeah.
是啊。
And then she took out her purse. And she reached into her purse, and then she gripped onto something. And I remember thinking like, oh, no. The way-- I thought--
然后她拿出了她的钱包。她伸手进钱包，抓住了什么东西。我记得我想，哦，不。那种方式——我想——
Oh, like it's like a gun or something?
哦，就像枪什么的？
Or a gun, or a knife, or something. I remember my heart just dropping. And then she pulled out a hairbrush. And then she just started brushing her hair, like at the foot of my bed.
或者是枪，或者是刀，或者其他什么。我记得我的心沉了下去。然后她掏出了一把梳子。然后她就开始梳头，就在我床尾。
Wow.
哇。
And then at that point, I was like, this is really weird. Like this is like--
在那一刻，我就想，这真的很奇怪。这就像是——
Right.
对。
And I don't think she's going to leave. And then she sat on the vanity in front of the mirror at the desk, and she took her earrings off.
我不认为她会离开。然后她在书桌前的梳妆台上坐下，取下了耳环。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
And she started taking-- she took her shoes off. She took her coat off. She was just like--
然后她开始脱——她脱掉了鞋子。她脱掉了外套。她就像是——
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
--making herself comfortable to be here now.
——让她自己现在舒服地待在这里。
Right.
对。
And so I let her do all that and was listening to her go on about what was wrong. And then, eventually, after I felt like enough time had passed, I said we have to wake up early to go to school tomorrow. And we're really tired, so I think we should probably go back to bed now.
所以我让她做了所有这些，听她讲什么地方出错了。然后，最终，在我觉得时间足够久了之后，我说我们要早起去上学。我们真的很累，所以我想我们现在应该上床睡觉了。
And she was like, I know, I know. I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry I'm here. I'm here. I'm sorry I'm here. And I said, no, it's totally fine that you're here-- almost like thank you for being here-- but do you mind leaving now?
她说，我知道，我知道。对不起，对不起，对不起我在这里。我在这里。对不起我在这里。我说，不，你在这里完全没关系——几乎就像谢谢你在这里——但你介意现在离开吗？
And so I very slowly stood up and walked over to the door. And every moment was making sure we're safe. And then I opened the door. And she said, OK, OK. And put her shoes on. And then she started to leave. And just as she was about to leave, I said, oh, you forgot your earrings.
所以我非常缓慢地站起来，走到门口。每一个时刻都是为了确保我们安全。然后我打开了门。她说，好的，好的。并穿上了鞋子。然后她开始离开。就在她要离开的时候，我说，哦，你忘了耳环了。
And then she started crying all over again, like it was this huge thing. Walked over to get the earrings, and then sat back down on the bed. And I remember thinking, god damn. Why did I bring up the earrings? We were so close to being safe.
然后她又开始哭了起来，好像那是什么天大的事。走回来拿耳环，然后又在床上坐下。我记得想，该死。我为什么要提耳环的事？我们离安全只有一步之遥。
So then basically, the whole thing started all over again where I had to listen to her cry, calm her down. And then finally, I'm like, you know, we have to wake up early to go to school. Do you mind leaving? And I walked her to the door, and she walked out of the door. And as soon as she was out of the door, I just pushed the door as hard as I could to close it. And when I pushed it, basically like slammed it shut, she screamed at the top of her lungs.
所以基本上，整件事又重新开始，我不得不听她哭，让她平静下来。最后，我说，你知道，我们要早起去上学。你介意离开吗？我把她带到门口，她走了出去。她一出门，我就拼尽全力推门关上。当我推门的时候，基本上就像重重地关上了，她放声尖叫。
And is there a bolt or something on the door?
门上有插销吗？
I think I did bolt it, after I slammed it shut. And then I heard her screaming in the hallway. And then she ran down the hallway screaming. And then she ran back towards the door screaming.
我想在我用力关上它之后，我确实上了插销。然后我听到她在走廊里尖叫。然后她尖叫着跑下走廊。然后她又尖叫着跑回门边。
That must've been terrifying.
那一定很可怕。
It was so scary. And then it was quiet. And then I heard this loud-- she's like banging on the door, as hard as she can, right? And then I hear a voice, and it's my dad. And my dad's like, open the door, open the door! And I realize it's not her banging on the door. So I open the door, and my dad's standing there. And he's like, did you hear someone screaming in the hallway?
那太可怕了。然后安静了。然后我听到这一声巨大的——她像是在敲门，尽可能用力，对吧？然后我听到一个声音，是我爸爸。我爸爸说，开门，开门！我意识到敲门的人不是她。所以我开了门，我爸爸站在那里。他说，你听到有人在走廊里尖叫吗？
So then I tell him this whole story. I'm like, there was this woman. She was in our room. I tell him all the details, and he is furious. He was so mad. And then he told us to stay there, shut the door, don't open the door. And then he went downstairs and talked to the hotel about it.
所以我告诉了他整个故事。我说，有一个女人。她在我们房间里。我告诉了他所有的细节，他很愤怒。他非常生气。然后他叫我们待在那里，关上门，不要开门。然后他下楼和酒店谈了这件事。
Yeah, and what did he learn?
是的，他了解到了什么？
They tell him that she had been outside. She was crying. They asked if she was a guest there. She said, yes. Her name was Elena Baker. And so they looked up the name.
他们告诉他她一直在外面。她在哭。他们问她是不是那里的客人。她说，是的。她叫 Elena Baker。所以他们查了这个名字。
Elena Baker?
Elena Baker？
Elena Baker, yeah.
Elena Baker，是的。
And your name is Elna Baker.
而你的名字是 Elna Baker。
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
But I don't believe this part of the story. I think someone at the hotel just said this to him to cover.
但我根本不相信故事的这部分。我认为酒店里的某个人只是为了掩盖事实才对他这么说的。
OK. And then they gave her a key?
好的。然后他们给了她一把钥匙？
And then they gave her a key. Yep. And so the hotel offered him the whole stay for free, everything for free. And he's like, I don't care about your money. I want you guys to do a formal investigation as to how this happened.
然后他们给了她一把钥匙。是的。所以酒店提出免费提供他整个住宿，一切免费。他说，我不关心你的钱。我要你们做一个正式的调查，关于这是怎么发生的。
Wow, that's such a white man takes charge move.
哇，那真是一个典型的白人男性负责的行为。
My dad isn't white.
我爸爸不是白人。
Oh, point taken.
哦，明白了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He's a Hispanic man. Passionate, with such a Hispanic passion.
他是西班牙裔。充满激情，带着一种西班牙裔的激情。
I was just thinking, you just never hear somebody be like, I demand a formal investigation. You know what I mean? It's like he's a member of Congress or something, you know?
我只是在想，你永远不会听到有人说，我要求进行正式调查。你知道我的意思吗？这就像他是国会议员什么的，你懂的？
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
All right. Anyway--
好吧。无论如何——
But I mean, that's totally how my dad would-- like, that's my dad.
但我的意思是，我爸爸完全会那样——就像，那就是我爸爸。
Point taken. OK.
明白了。好的。
And so they do a formal investigation, which they then send to my dad.
所以他们进行了正式调查，然后发给了我爸爸。
Long after you've gone from the hotel.
在你离开酒店很久之后。
Exactly. And in it, there's a picture of the woman. And then there's her history. She had been in a psychiatric hospital and escaped that night, come to the hotel. And she had a long history of breaking into people's homes. And he's not certain about this part, so I don't--
确实。里面有那个女人的照片。还有她的历史。她曾在一个精神病院，那天晚上逃了出来，来到了酒店。她有长期闯入民宅的历史。他不确定这部分，所以我不知道——
He doesn't remember it.
他不记得了。
He doesn't remember, but he says that he remembers there being like she had attacked people when she'd broken into their homes.
他不记得了，但他说是他记得那里有像她在闯入民宅时袭击过人。
That's what he remembers.
这是他记得的。
Yeah.
是啊。
That part of the story, the investigation, who the woman was, Elna only found that out a couple years ago, when she asked her dad about it. At the time, back when she was 14, her parents kept all that from her and her brother and sisters. They didn't want them to dwell on it or make them afraid of the world. They didn't want that evening to become a bigger deal than it already was. And Elna says today, that worked.
故事的那部分，调查，那个女人是谁，Elna 只是在几年前才发现的，当时她问她爸爸这件事。当时，当她 14 岁时，她的父母对她、她弟弟和妹妹隐瞒了一切。他们不想让他们纠结于此或使他们害怕世界。他们不想让那个晚上变得比已经发生的情况更严重。Elna 说今天看来，奏效了。
And it's funny. Even as I've told this story over the years, people are like, oh that's so traumatic, or that's crazy. And I don't want to think of it like that.
很有趣。即使我多年来讲述这个故事，人们也说，哦，这太创伤了，或者这太疯狂了。但我不想那样想。
How so?
怎么讲？
It just was sort of like a-- because nothing bad happened, it has no category for me, if that makes sense. It was easier to just think like, oh, this weird thing happened one night when we were in a hotel.
这只是某种像——因为没发生什么坏事，它对我来说没有类别，如果这有意义的话。把这件事想成，哦，我们在酒店时那天晚上发生了件奇怪的事，这更容易。
In retrospect, would you have preferred if they had told you back when you were 14?
回过头来看，如果他们在你 14 岁时告诉你，你会更喜欢吗？
No, I think it's good that I got to live in a world that I think is safe.
不，我认为我能活在一个我认为安全的世界里很好。
On the other hand, she says if they had made clear how much danger she was in, the family's memory of it and her memory of it wouldn't be of this weird event with no category, this random thing that happened one night. Instead, it would fit squarely into the category called victory, solid win for 14-year-old girl in a big religious family when she got that stranger out of their hotel room without anybody getting hurt.
另一方面，她说如果他们清楚地表明她处于多大的危险之中，家人对它的记忆和她对它的记忆就不会是关于这个没有类别、那个晚上发生的随机事件的奇怪事件。相反，它会完全归入名为“胜利”的类别，对于大家庭中 14 岁的女孩来说是一个坚实的胜利，因为她让那个陌生人离开了他们的酒店房间而没人受伤。
And Elna says she would have liked that win. When you're trapped inside of a room with an unpredictable person, really, all you've got is your wits, and your ability to read the situation, and your judgment at guessing what will work. Nice to show everybody that even a kid can make the right call sometimes, if they pay attention closely enough.
Elna 说她会喜欢那场胜利。当你被困在一个有着不可预测的人的房间里时，其实，你所拥有的只是你的智慧，你阅读局势的能力，以及你猜测什么有效的能力。很高兴向大家展示，只要足够仔细观察，即使是一个孩子也能做出正确的决定。
Act Two, You Can't Go Your Own Way.
第二幕，你不能走自己的路。
There's this piece of writing that for months we've been trying to figure out how to get onto the radio, trying to figure out a theme where we could conceivably run it. And it's about somebody stuck in a bad relationship, in this case, an abusive relationship. And it tries to capture what that feels like, in particular all the mental energy that somebody in that situation can put into trying to figure out exactly what they should do to avoid setting off their partner.
有一篇文章，几个月来我们一直在想办法把它放上广播，试图想出一个可以设想运行它的主题。它是关于某人被困在一段糟糕的关系中，在这种情况下，一段虐待关系。它试图捕捉那种感觉，特别是某人在这种情况下可以投入的所有精神能量，试图弄清楚他们应该确切做什么来避免触动他们的伴侣。
In her memoir, In The Dream House, Carmen Maria Machado invented this totally ingenious way to get that feeling across. There's this chapter that's a "choose your own adventure" where she imagines different choices that she could have made. A heads up that this excerpt includes a scene with sexual content. It's read first by actor Zoë Winters.
在她的回忆录《梦之屋》中，Carmen Maria Machado 发明了一种非常巧妙的方法来传达那种感觉。这一章是一个“选择你自己的冒险”，她想象了她可以做出的不同选择。提醒一下，这段摘录包含性内容。首先由演员 Zoë Winters 朗读。
Page 1, you wake up, and the air is milky and bright. The room glows with a kind of effervescent contentment, despite the boxes, and clothes, and dishes. You think to yourself, this is the kind of morning you could get used to.
第 1 页，你醒了，空气奶白而明亮。尽管有盒子、衣服和盘子，房间闪烁着一种冒泡的满足感。你心想，这是你可以适应的那种早晨。
When you turn over, she is staring at you. The luminous innocence of the light curdles in your stomach. You don't remember ever going from awake to afraid so quickly.
当你转过身时，她正盯着你。光线的发光纯真在你的胃里凝固了。你不记得曾经这么快地从清醒变得恐惧。
"You were moving all night," she says. "Your arms and elbows touched me. You kept me awake." If you apologize profusely, go to page 2. If you tell her to wake you up next time your elbows touch her in your sleep, go to page 3. If you tell her to calm down, go to page 5.
“你整晚都在动，”她说。“你的手臂和手肘碰到了我。你让我无法入睡。”如果你道歉，翻到第 2 页。如果你告诉她下次你的手肘在睡梦中碰到她时叫醒你，翻到第 3 页。如果你告诉她冷静点，翻到第 5 页。
I choose page 2. Page 2. "I'm so sorry," you tell her. "I really didn't mean to. I just move my arms around a lot in my sleep." You try to be light about it. "Did you know my dad does the same thing? The sleeping damsel swoon? So weird. I must have--" "Are you really sorry?" she says. "I don't think you are." "I am," you say.
我选择第 2 页。第 2 页。“非常抱歉，”你告诉她。“我真的不是故意的。我只是睡着时手臂动得太多。”你试图轻描淡写地说。“你知道我爸爸也做同样的事吗？睡着的女巫昏厥？真奇怪。我一定——”“你真的感到抱歉吗？”她说。“我觉得你不觉得。”“我感到，”你说。
You want the first impression of the morning to return to you, its freshness, its light. "I really am." "Prove it." "How?" "Stop doing it." "I told you. I can't." "Fuck you," she says, and gets out of bed. You follow her all the way to the kitchen. Go to page 7.
你想要早晨的第一印象回到你身上，它的新鲜感，它的光。 “我真的感到。” “证明它。” “怎么证明？” “别再那样做了。” “我告诉过你。我做不到。” “操你，”她说，并下床。你一路跟着她到厨房。翻到第 7 页。
Page 7, breakfast. You scramble some eggs, make some toast. She eats mechanically and leaves the plate on the table. "Clean that up," she says as she goes to the bedroom to get dressed.
第 7 页，早餐。你炒了一些鸡蛋，做了些吐司。她机械地吃着，把盘子留在桌子上。“清理掉，”她在去卧室穿衣服时说。
If you stare mutely at the dirty plate and all you can think about is Clara Barton, the feminist icon of your youth who had to teach herself how to be a nurse and endured abuse from men telling her what to do at every turn, and you remember being so angry and running to your parents and asking them if women still got told what was right or proper, and your mom said, yes, and your dad said, no, and you, for the first time had an inkling of how complicated and terrible the world was, go to page 10. If you do as you are told, go to page 8. If you tell her to do it herself, go to page 5.
如果你哑口无言地盯着那个脏盘子，你唯一能想到的是 Clara Barton，你年轻时的女权偶像，她不得不自学如何成为护士，并忍受男人们告诉她该做什么的虐待，你记得自己当时非常生气，跑去告诉父母，问他们女性是否仍然被告知什么才是正确或适当的，你妈妈说，是的，你爸爸说，不，你第一次意识到世界是多么复杂和可怕，翻到第 10 页。如果你照办，翻到第 8 页。如果你告诉她自己做，翻到第 5 页。
Page 5-- are you kidding? You'd never do this. Don't try to convince any of these people that you'd stand up for yourself for one second. Get out of here. Go to the next chapter. You're out.
第 5 页——你在开玩笑吗？你永远不会这样做。别试图说服这些人和你站在一起。快离开这儿。去下一章。你出局了。
Wait. No. Let's try that again. I go to page 8. Page 8. As you're washing the dishes, you think to yourself, maybe I should put a tack on my forehand. Maybe I should be a better person. Go to page 1.
等等。不。让我们再试一次。我去第 8 页。第 8 页。当你洗碗时，你心想，也许我应该更努力。也许我应该成为一个更好的人。翻到第 1 页。
Page 1. You wake up, and the air is milky and bright. The room glows with a kind of effervescent contentment, despite the boxes, and clothes, and dishes. You think to yourself this is the kind of morning you could get used to. When you turn over, she is staring at you. The luminous innocence of the light curdles in your stomach. You don't remember ever going from awake to afraid so quickly.
第 1 页。你醒了，空气奶白而明亮。尽管有盒子、衣服和盘子，房间闪烁着一种冒泡的满足感。你心想，这是你可以适应的那种早晨。当你转过身时，她正盯着你。光线的发光纯真在你的胃里凝固了。你不记得曾经这么快地从清醒变得恐惧。
"You were moving all night", she says. "Your arms and elbows touched me. You kept me awake." If you apologize profusely, go to page 2. If you tell her to calm down, go to page 5. If you tell her to wake you up next time your elbows touch her in your sleep, go to page 3.
“你整晚都在动，”她说。“你的手臂和手肘碰到了我。你让我无法入睡。”如果你道歉，翻到第 2 页。如果你告诉她冷静点，翻到第 5 页。如果你告诉她下次你的手肘在睡梦中碰到她时叫醒你，翻到第 3 页。
I go to page 3. Page 3. "Baby, if this ever happens in the future, you can always wake me up, and I'll go to the couch. I promise. I really don't mean to do it. I don't have any memory of it. I can't control how I move in my sleep."
我去第 3 页。第 3 页。“宝贝，如果这种情况将来再次发生，你可以随时叫醒我，我会去沙发上睡。我保证。我真的不是故意的。我对此没有任何记忆。我无法控制我在睡梦中如何移动。”
"You are such a fucking cunt," she says. "You never take responsibility for anything." "Well, all you have to do is wake me up," you say, a kind of incoherent desperation zipping through your skull. "That's it. Wake me up and tell me to move or sleep on the couch, and I will do it. I swear to you." "Fuck you," she says, and gets out of bed. You follow her to the kitchen. Go to page 7.
“你真是个他妈的混蛋，”她说。“你从来不对任何事情负责。”“好吧，你只需要叫醒我，”你说，一种不连贯的绝望在你的头骨中穿梭。“就这样。叫醒我，告诉我移动或去沙发上睡，我会做的。我对你发誓。”“操你，”她说，并下床。你跟着她去厨房。翻到第 7 页。
Page 7. Breakfast. You scramble some eggs, make some toast. She eats mechanically and leaves the plate on the table. "Clean that up," she says, as she goes to the bedroom to get dressed.
第 7 页。早餐。你炒了一些鸡蛋，做了些吐司。她机械地吃着，把盘子留在桌子上。“清理掉，”她在去卧室穿衣服时说。
If you do as you are told, go to page 8. If you tell her to do it herself, go to page 5. If you stare mutely at the dirty plate, and all you can think about is Clara Barton, the feminist icon of your youth who had to teach herself how to be a nurse and endured abuse from men, telling her what to do at every turn, and you remember being so angry and running to your parents and asking them if women still got told what was right or proper, and your mom said yes, and your dad said no, and you, for the first time, had an inkling of how complicated and terrible the world was, go to page 10.
如果你照办，翻到第 8 页。如果你告诉她自己做，翻到第 5 页。如果你哑口无言地盯着那个脏盘子，你唯一能想到的是 Clara Barton，你年轻时的女权偶像，她不得不自学如何成为护士，并忍受男人们告诉她该做什么的虐待，你记得自己当时非常生气，跑去告诉父母，问他们女性是否仍然被告知什么才是正确或适当的，你妈妈说，是的，你爸爸说，不，你第一次意识到世界是多么复杂和可怕，翻到第 10 页。
Page 10. That night, she fucks you as you lie there mutely, praying for it to be over, praying she won't notice you're gone. You have voided your body so many times by now that it is force of habit, reflexive as a sigh. It reminds you of your first boyfriend, who fucked you while watching porn, how he rutted and rutted, and then every so often lifted the remote to rewind something you couldn't see.
第 10 页。那天晚上，她强暴你，你哑口无言地躺在那里，祈祷它结束，祈祷她不会注意到你离开了。你已经多次清空了你的身体，以至于它成了习惯，像叹息一样反射性。它让我想起我的第一个男朋友，他在看色情片时强暴了我，他如何反复抽动，然后每隔一段时间就拿起遥控器倒回一些你看不到的东西。
Once you turned your head over the lip of the bed and saw a tangle of upside down limbs, and your brain couldn't make sense of them. You never looked again. You would just lie there silently, watching his face move over you. It was like being unfolded beneath the yawn of the planetarium as a kid-- the sped up rotation of the Earth, the movement of the stars, the constellations melting into and out of being.
有一次你把头转向床边，看到一团倒置的肢体，你的大脑无法理解它们。你再也没看过。你只是静静地躺在那里，看着他的脸在你身上移动。那就像小时候在天文馆的哈欠下展开一样——地球的加速旋转，星星的运动，星座融入又消失。
You shudder and moan with precision. She turns off the lights. You watch the darkness until the darkness leaves you, or you leave it.
你精确地颤抖和呻吟。她关掉了灯。你看着黑暗，直到黑暗离开你，或者你离开它。
To sleep, go to page 14. To dream about the present, go to page 13. To dream about the future, go to page 12. To dream about the past, go to page 11. I want to dream about the past. I choose page 11.
睡觉，翻到第 14 页。梦到当下，翻到第 13 页。梦到未来，翻到第 12 页。梦到过去，翻到第 11 页。我想梦到过去。我选择第 11 页。
Page 11. The first time it happened, the first time she yelled at you so much you were crying within 30 seconds from waking, a record. She said, "The first 10 minutes of the day, I'm not responsible for anything I say." This struck you as poetic. You even wrote it down, sure you would find a place for it in a book, maybe. Go to page 14.
第 11 页。第一次发生时，第一次她对你大喊大叫，以至于你在醒来后 30 秒内就哭了，创下记录。她说，“这一天的前 10 分钟，我对我说的一切都不负责。”这让你觉得很诗意。你甚至把它写了下来，确定你会在书里找到它的位置，也许。翻到第 14 页。
Page 9. You shouldn't be on this page. There's no way to get here from the choices given to you. Do you think that by flipping through this chapter linearly you'd find some kind of relief? Don't you get it? All of this shit already happened. And you can't make it not happen, no matter what you do.
第 9 页。你不应该在这个页面上。从给你的选择中没有办法来到这里。你认为通过线性翻阅这一章你会找到某种解脱吗？你不明白吗？所有这些狗屎已经发生了。无论你做什么，你都无法让它不发生。
Do you want a picture of a fawn? Will that help? OK, here's a fawn. She is small and dappled and loose legged. She hears a sound, freezes, and then bolts. She knows what to do. She knows there's somewhere safer she can be.
你想要一张小鹿的照片吗？那会有帮助吗？好吧，这里有一只小鹿。她是小小的，有斑点的，腿很松。她听到声音，僵住了，然后跑了。她知道该怎么做。她知道有一个更安全的地方可以去。
Go to page 10. I don't want to go to page 10.
翻到第 10 页。我不想去第 10 页。
Page 6. You shouldn't be on this page. There's no way to get here from the choices given to you. You flipped here because you got sick of the cycle. You wanted to get out. You're smarter than me. Go to page 10. Fine. I go to page 10.
第 6 页。你不应该在这个页面上。从给你的选择中没有办法来到这里。你翻到这里是因为你厌倦了循环。你想出去。你比我聪明。翻到第 10 页。好吧。我去第 10 页。
Page 10. That night she fucks you as you lie there mutely, praying for it to be over, praying she won't notice you're gone. You have voided your body so many times by now that it is force of habit, reflexive as a sigh. It reminds you of-- [FADE OUT]
第 10 页。那天晚上她强暴你，你哑口无言地躺在那里，祈祷它结束，祈祷她不会注意到你离开了。你已经多次清空了你的身体，以至于它成了习惯，像叹息一样反射性。它让我想起——[淡出]
[FADE IN] --sped up rotation of the Earth, the movement of the stars, the constellations melting into and out of being. You shudder and moan with precision. She turns off the lights. You watch the darkness until the darkness leaves you, or you leave it. To sleep, go to page 14. To dream about the past, go to page 11. To dream about the present, go to page 13.
[淡入] ——地球的加速旋转，星星的运动，星座融入又消失。你精确地颤抖和呻吟。她关掉了灯。你看着黑暗，直到黑暗离开你，或者你离开它。睡觉，翻到第 14 页。梦到过去，翻到第 11 页。梦到当下，翻到第 13 页。
Page 13. You shouldn't be here, but it's OK. It's a dream. She can't find you here.
第 13 页。你不应该在这里，但没关系。这是一个梦。她在这里找不到你。
In a minute, you're going to wake up, and everything is going to seem like it's the same, but it's not. There's a way out. Are you listening to me? You can't forget when you wake up. You can't go to page 14. I want to dream about the future. I go to page 12.
一分钟后，你会醒来，一切看起来都一样，但并非如此。有出路。你在听我说话吗？醒来后你不能忘记。你不能翻到第 14 页。我想梦到未来。我去第 12 页。
Page 12. It's going to be all right. One day, your wife will gently adjust your arm if it touches her face at night, soothingly straightening it while kissing you. Sometimes, you will wake up just enough to notice. Other times, she'll only tell you in the morning. It's the kind of morning you could get used to. Go to page 14.
第 12 页。一切都会好起来的。有一天，你的妻子会在晚上轻轻调整你的手臂，如果它碰到她的脸，舒缓地把它伸直，同时吻你。有时，你会醒来刚好注意到。其他时候，她只会在早上告诉你。这是你可以适应的那种早晨。翻到第 14 页。
Page 14. You wake up, and the air is milky and bright. The room glows with a kind of effervescent contentment, despite the boxes, and clothes, and dishes. You think to yourself, this is the kind of morning you could get used to. When you turn over, she is staring at you. The luminous innocence of the light curdles in your stomach. You don't remember ever going from awake to afraid so quickly.
第 14 页。你醒了，空气奶白而明亮。尽管有盒子、衣服和盘子，房间闪烁着一种冒泡的满足感。你心想，这是你可以适应的那种早晨。当你转过身时，她正盯着你。光线的发光纯真在你的胃里凝固了。你不记得曾经这么快地从清醒变得恐惧。
"You were moving all night," she says. "Your arms and elbows touched me. You kept me awake." If you apologize profusely, go to page 2. If you tell her to wake you up next time your elbows touch her in your sleep, go to page 3.
“你整晚都在动，”她说。“你的手臂和手肘碰到了我。你让我无法入睡。”如果你道歉，翻到第 2 页。如果你告诉她下次你的手肘在睡梦中碰到她时叫醒你，翻到第 3 页。
If you toss back the blankets from your body and hit the floor with both feet and tear through the house like it's Pamplona, and when you get to the driveway, your car keys are already in your hand, and you drive away with a theatrical squeal of the tires never to return again, go to page 15. Page 15. That's not how it happened, but OK. We can pretend. I'll give it to you, just this once. Turn to page 16.
如果你从身上掀开毯子，两脚落地，像在潘普洛纳一样冲过房子，当你到达车道时，你的车钥匙已经在手里了，你以戏剧性的轮胎尖叫声开车离开，再也不回来，翻到第 15 页。第 15 页。这不是发生的情况，但好吧。我们可以假装。我给你一次机会，就这一次。翻到第 16 页。
Page 16, an end. In the pit of it, you fantasize about dying, tripping on a sidewalk and stumbling into the path of an oncoming car, a gas leak silently offing you in your sleep, a machete-wielding madman on public transit, falling down the stairs, but drunk, so you flop limb over limb like a marionette and feel no pain-- anything to make it stop. You have forgotten that leaving is an option.
第 16 页，结束。在这一切的深处，你幻想死亡，在人行道上绊倒，跌入迎面而来的车道，煤气泄漏在睡梦中悄悄带走你，公共交通上的疯子挥舞砍刀，从楼梯上摔下来，但喝醉了，所以你像木偶一样肢体交叠，没有任何痛苦——任何能让它停止的事。你已经忘记离开是一个选项。
Zoë Winters, reading a chapter from Carmen Maria Machado's memoir In The Dream House.
Zoë Winters，朗读 Carmen Maria Machado 的回忆录《梦之屋》中的一章。
Coming up, a family in quarantine thinks it's figured everything out, doing everything perfectly, until evidence of one tiny, tiny mistake. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一个处于隔离状态的家庭认为已经弄清楚了一切，做得尽善尽美，直到出现了一个小小的错误。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Stuck. For these long lockdown days, and weeks, and months, stories of people trapped in one situation or another for long stretches, stuck. I say this, recording these words in a closet at home. Here, I'm going to tap. That's the sound of me tapping hangers and a shirt.
这里是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。今天的节目，困境。在这些漫长的封锁日子里，以及几周、几个月，关于人们在某种情况下被困在一段很长的时间里的故事，被困住了。我这么说，是在家里壁橱里录下这些话的。在这里，我要拍打。这是我拍打衣架和衬衫的声音。
So this writer named Damon Linker wrote this column for the magazine and website The Week about how, right now, with schools and jobs shut down, we've all become unmoored from the future. We're stuck in the present. And it's unclear when we're going to move forward to graduation, or a new job, or whatever else we're building for ourselves and our lives in a normal time we would be looking forward to.
所以这个名叫 Damon Linker 的作家为杂志和网站《The Week》写了这篇专栏，关于现在，随着学校和工作关闭，我们所有人都从未来中脱离了。我们被困在当下。不清楚我们什么时候会向前迈进到毕业，或一份新工作，或任何我们在正常时间里会期待的为了自己和生活建立的东西。
And he tries to make the case that this is a big, big deal. "Human beings live their lives in time", he writes. "Our sense of ourselves is partly who we're trying to become." Quote, "A life without forward momentum is to a considerable extent a life without purpose, or at least the kind of purpose that lifts our spirits and enlivens our steps. Without the momentum and purpose, we flounder. A present without a future is a life that feels less worth living, because it's a life haunted by a shadow of futility." End quote.
他试图证明这是一个非常、非常大的问题。“人类在时间中生活，”他写道。“我们对自己的一部分感官是我们试图成为的样子。”引述，“一个没有前进动力的生活在很大程度上是一个没有目的的生活，或者至少是那种能提升我们的精神、活跃我们的步伐的目的。没有动力和目的，我们就会挣扎。一个没有未来的现在是一种感觉不那么值得活下去的生活，因为它是一种被虚无的阴影所困扰的生活。”引用结束。
I have to say, I've thought about that so much these last few weeks, because so many people that I'm close to I just see how they are stressed out by how weirdly formless their days have become. The normal routine is all gone. And all of us have only the cloudiest sense of what the future is going to be. Act Three of our program today is about a family that is in that limbo, hunkered down, trying to get by. When you're stuck indoors for long stretches of time, weird things can happen.
我必须说，过去几周我一直在思考这个问题，因为我和这么多亲近的人在一起，我看到他们是如何因为日子变得如此古怪地不成形而感到压力巨大。正常的作风全都消失了。我们所有人都对未来会是什么样子只有最模糊的认识。我们节目今天的第三幕是关于一个处于那种不确定状态的家庭，窝在家里，试图熬过去。当你被困在室内很长一段时间时，奇怪的事情可能会发生。
So let's get to this. This is Act Three, Cold Case.
所以让我们进入这个。这是第三幕，冷案。
So you know those locked room detective stories where there's a crime in some room, and it's unclear how the culprit even got into the room? This next story is kind of about that sort of situation. One of our producers, Nadia Reiman, explains.
所以你知道那些密室侦探故事，有些房间发生了犯罪，但不清楚罪犯是怎么进到房间里的？接下来的故事就是关于那种情况的。我们的制作人之一，Nadia Reiman，解释道。
This thing happened recently that made no sense to me at all. My family's been isolating in suburban Rochester, New York, where my parents live, and I mean hardcore isolating. We see no one, we go nowhere. We haven't been inside a store or been around other humans in two months.
最近发生的一件事对我来说根本说不通。我的家人一直待在纽约州罗切斯特郊区自我隔离，我父母住那里，我的意思是彻底隔离。我们不见任何人，哪里都不去。我们两个月来没有进过商店，也没有接触过其他人。
For food, we do curbside pickup or delivery, which privilege, I know. Then we do this insane disinfection process where we wipe everything down with a 90% rubbing alcohol, 10% water solution we made ourselves.
为了食物，我们做路边提货或送货，我知道这是特权。然后我们做了这种疯狂的消毒过程，我们用自己制作的 90% 的外用酒精和 10% 的水溶液擦拭一切。
When we're done, the room smells like a sterilized doctor's office. When we go for walks, if we see anyone, we cross the street a block ahead. We pick up all mail with disposable gloves, leave it in the garage for 24 hours. We used to spray with Lysol first. We agreed that was overkill. But to be honest, I still do it behind my family's back.
当我们完成时，房间闻起来像消毒过的医生办公室。当我们散步时，如果我们看到任何人，我们提前一个街区过马路。我们用一次性手套处理所有邮件，在车库里放 24 小时。我们过去先用 Lysol 喷。我们同意那是过度了。但老实说，我仍然背着家人这样做。
So in my mind, there is no way any germ could break through our impenetrable disinfectant fortress. But somehow, after doing this day after day for seven straight weeks--
所以在我看来，没有任何病菌能穿过我们刀枪不入的消毒堡垒。但不知何故，在连续七周每天这样做之后——
Yeah, I woke up fairly early in the morning and felt it. I think I have a cold.
是的，我早上起得相当早，感觉到了。我想我得了感冒。
That's my husband, Jeremy.
那是我的丈夫 Jeremy。
I was rundown, runny nose, sore throat.
我感到精疲力竭、流鼻涕、喉咙痛。
In a couple of days, he was fine. But I was like, how the hell did that even happen? How could he possibly have gotten a cold?
几天内，他好了。但我当时想，这到底是怎么发生的？他怎么可能感冒？
We've been super careful, because he has an immune deficiency, one that affects his respiratory system. It keeps me up at night, sometimes. Because if the cold virus made it into our house, then the coronavirus could too. It meant there was a crack in our armor. I needed to know where we had failed, so Jeremy and I consulted an expert at a very safe social distance.
我们一直非常小心，因为他有免疫缺陷，一种影响他呼吸系统的缺陷。这有时让我彻夜难眠。因为如果感冒病毒进入了我们的房子，那么冠状病毒也可能进入。这意味着我们的铠甲上有一道裂缝。我需要知道我们在哪里失败了，所以 Jeremy 和我在一个非常安全的社交距离下咨询了一位专家。
Where are you?
你在哪里？
I'm in Cardiff, Wales, United Kingdom. And I'm on the coast here, so I'm looking out over the sea. So I'm really well isolated.
我在英国威尔士卡迪夫。我在海岸，所以我正看着大海。所以我隔离得非常好。
This is Ron Eccles, who really knows about colds. Studied them for 50 years. He ran a place called the Common Cold Center at Cardiff University. Almost immediately, I told him all the precautions we were taking.
这是 Ron Eccles，他真的很了解感冒。研究了它们 50 年。他经营着卡迪夫大学的一个名为普通感冒中心的地方。几乎立刻，我告诉了他我们正在采取的所有预防措施。
I don't understand how this is physically possible. I just really want to know how did this happen? How could he have gotten this?
我不明白这在物理上是怎么可能的。我只是真的很想知道这是怎么发生的？他怎么会得这个？
Well, it's a bit of a mystery. Let me see if I can ask you some questions to work through it, rather like a detective. You say you've not actually met anybody, so I assume you've not physically touched anybody, shaken hands, or anything like that.
嗯，这有点神秘。让我试着问你一些问题来弄清楚它，就像侦探一样。你说你实际上没有见过任何人，所以我假设你没有身体接触过任何人，握手或类似的事情。
No, not at all.
不，一点也没有。
What about the door handle outside? Does anybody else touch that door handle, perhaps to open it? A cleaner or a delivery man?
外面的门把手怎么样？还有其他人接触那个门把手吗，也许是为了打开它？清洁工或送货员？
Well, so here's what I've done. Every time we go out the house, I started to spray the door handle with Lysol. And now I made the paint come off, so there's like a big streak going down the middle of it, because I've sprayed it so much.
嗯，所以我做了这个。每次我们出门，我都开始用 Lysol 喷门把手。现在油漆都脱落了，中间有一条大条纹，因为我喷得太多了。
I can personally guarantee that doorknob is safe.
我可以个人担保那个门把手是安全的。
The next way you could pick up a cold from someone is by what we call an aerosol. And these are just tiny particles. Is there any way that someone could have been outside, and coughing and sneezing, and maybe small particles have come in? Is that a possibility?
从别人那里感冒的下一个方式是你所说的气溶胶。这些只是微小的颗粒。有没有可能有人在外面，咳嗽和打喷嚏，也许小颗粒进来了？那是可能性吗？
That seemed like the only possible way. Because we will see people jogging, walking towards us, and we'll cross the street. And so if there's any potential for them to have sneezed or coughed in the trail--
那似乎是唯一可能的方式。因为我们会看到有人在跑步，走向我们，我们会穿过街道。所以如果他们有可能在路上打喷嚏或咳嗽——
Yeah, that's a possibility, if you're caught downwind from them.
是的，如果你在顺风处被他们传染，那是有可能的。
I mean, sure, but pretty damn unlikely. Eccles moves onto a different line of questioning.
我的意思是，确实，但非常不可能。Eccles 转向了另一条询问路线。
I'm homing in now on two possibilities for Jeremy. Did Jeremy experience any itching at all with this episode that he had, itching in the throat or nose? Because if you had any itching, I would tend to think that it could be some sort of allergy.
我现在正在专注于 Jeremy 的两种可能性。Jeremy 在他经历的这一集中有任何发痒的感觉吗，喉咙或鼻子发痒？因为如果有任何发痒，我会倾向于认为这可能是某种过敏。
No. No, not that I can recall.
没有。没有，我不记得了。
And he's been tested twice. No allergies. Which leaves one last possibility, one I didn't even imagine, like not in my wildest dreams. The thing that made him sick, it was inside him all along.
而且他被测试了两次。没有过敏。这就剩下最后一种可能性，我甚至没想过，在最疯狂的梦中也没想过。让他生病的东西，一直都在他体内。
We are carrying a lot of bacteria around in our throat and nose, normally. Now, if we get stressed-- and you did mention that Jeremy did have a bit of a slight immune deficiency, but stress causes us to get even more immune deficient-- then it's possible that some of the bacteria that are normally hanging around in the throat or nose of Jeremy have taken that opportunity of low immunity to make a bit of an infection.
我们通常在喉咙和鼻子中携带大量细菌。现在，如果我们感到压力——你确实提到 Jeremy 有一点轻微的免疫缺陷，但压力会导致我们更加免疫缺陷——那么，Jeremy 喉咙或鼻子中通常徘徊的一些细菌利用那个低免疫的机会制造了一点感染，这是有可能的。
So I think I'm proving that it's probably a bacterial infection, because I can't see how on Earth you would have got a cold with all the precautions that you're taking.
所以我认为我正在证明这可能是细菌感染，因为我看不出你在采取所有这些预防措施的情况下怎么会感冒。
So he had a cold inside of him already?
所以他体内已经有感冒了？
Not a virus, but a bacterium. But it's masquerading as a common cold.
不是病毒，而是细菌。但它伪装成普通感冒。
That's his best guess. Basically, the call was coming from inside the house.
那是他最好的猜测。基本上，电话来自房子里面。
How long would Jeremy have been like-- how long would it have been just hanging out there with him? Could it be like months? Could it be something that he had since before the seven weeks that we've been up here?
Jeremy 会那样多久——它会和他待在一起多久？可能是几个月吗？可能是他在我们待在这里的七周之前就有的东西吗？
Oh, yes. It could be years.
哦，是的。可能是几年。
Really?
真的？
Years.
几年。
It felt good. It meant there was no hole in the armor. All the wiping, the spraying, it was working. Everything was fine. Jeremy also felt good, kind of.
感觉很好。这意味着铠甲上没有洞。所有的擦拭，喷洒，都有作用。一切都好。Jeremy 也感觉不错，某种程度上。
I think in some ways, I might feel less relieved now, because now it feels like it just lives in me and that it's just always there waiting to try to kill me.
我认为在某些方面，我现在可能感觉没那么宽慰了，因为现在感觉它只是住在我体内，而且它一直都在那里等待着试图杀死我。
Don't worry, Jeremy. We all have the same bacteria.
别担心，Jeremy。我们都有同样的细菌。
But it's coming after me.
但它在追我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have a small confession to make. When Jeremy first told me he felt sick, honestly, I didn't really believe him. I love him, but I thought he was just tired. Turns out, he was right. He was sick. It was real. So here you go. Jeremy, you were right. Sorry, love.
我有一个小小的告白要说。当 Jeremy 第一次告诉我他感觉不舒服时，老实说，我真的不相信他。我爱他，但我以为他只是累了。事实证明，他是对的。他生病了。那是真的。所以给你。Jeremy，你是对的。对不起，亲爱的。
Nadia Reiman is one of the producers of our show.
Nadia Reiman 是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Four, Unhappy Accident. So we end our show today with a story from our archive of somebody stuck in a momentary difficult situation. It comes from Etkar Keret. The story is all true. It happens in Israel, where Etkar lives, and was read for us in English translation by actor, Michael Chernus.
第四幕，不幸的事故。所以我们今天以来自我们档案的故事结束我们的节目，关于某人被困在暂时困难的情况下。它来自 Etkar Keret。这个故事完全是真的。它发生在以色列，Etkar 居住的地方，由演员 Michael Chernus 为我们翻译朗读。
"30 years I'm a cabbie", the small guy sitting behind the wheel tells me. "30 years and not one accident." It's been almost an hour since I got into his taxi in Beersheba, and he hasn't stopped talking for a second.
“做了 30 年出租车司机，”坐在方向盘后面的小个子告诉我。“30 年了，没出过一次事故。”自从我在贝尔谢巴上他的出租车以来，已经快一个小时了，他一秒钟也没停过说话。
Under different circumstances, I would tell him to shut up, but I don't have the energy for that today. Under different circumstances, I wouldn't shell out 350 shekels to take a taxi to Tel Aviv. I would take the train. But today I feel that I have to get home as early as I can.
在不同的情况下，我会叫他闭嘴，但我今天没那个精力了。在不同的情况下，我不会花 350 谢克尔打车去特拉维夫。我会坐火车。但今天我觉得我必须尽早回家。
I spent last night at Ichilov Hospital with my wife. She had a miscarriage and was bleeding heavily. We thought it would be OK, till she passed out. It wasn't until we got to the emergency room that they told us that her life was in danger and gave her a blood transfusion.
我昨晚在 Ichilov 医院陪我的妻子。她流产了，流血很严重。我们以为会没事的，直到她昏了过去。直到我们到了急诊室，他们才告诉我们她的生命有危险，并给她输了血。
Three days before that, my dad's doctors told me and my parents that the cancer at the base of his tongue, which had been in remission for four years, was back. And the tumor was at such an advanced stage that the only way to fight it was to remove his tongue and larynx.
在那之前的三天，我父亲的医生告诉我和我的父母，他舌根的癌症，已经缓解了四年，又回来了。而且肿瘤处于如此晚期的阶段，唯一的对抗方法就是切除他的舌头和喉头。
The oncologist said she didn't recommend having the surgery, but my dad said that he was for it. The oncologist told him that the operation would leave him seriously handicapped, unable to speak or eat. "At my age," my dad said, "all I need are my heart and my eyes, so I can enjoy watching my grandchildren grow." When we left the room, the doctor whispered to me, "Try to talk to him." She clearly doesn't know my dad.
肿瘤科医生说她不建议手术，但我父亲说他支持。肿瘤科医生告诉他手术会让他严重残疾，无法说话或进食。“在我这个年纪，”我父亲说，“我只需要我的心脏和眼睛，这样我就可以享受看着我的孙子们成长。”当我们离开房间时，医生对我耳语道，“试着和他谈谈。”她显然不了解我父亲。
The taxi driver repeats for the hundredth time that, in 30 years, he hasn't had a single accident. And that all of a sudden five days ago, his car kissed the bumper of the car in front of him, traveling at 20 kilometers per hour. When they stopped and checked, he saw that, except for a scratch on the left side of the bumper, the other car hadn't really been damaged at all. He offered the other driver 200 shekels on the spot, but the driver insisted that they exchange insurance information.
出租车司机第一百次重复说，在 30 年里，他没出过一次事故。而且五天前，他的车突然亲了一下前面那辆车的保险杠，时速 20 公里。当他们停下来检查时，他看到，除了保险杠左侧的划痕，另一辆车根本没损坏。他当场给了另一位司机 200 谢克尔，但那位司机坚持要交换保险信息。
The next day, the driver, a Russian, asked him to come to a garage. And he and the owner, probably a friend of his, showed him a huge dent all the way on the other side of the car and said the damage was 2,000 shekels. The cab driver refused to pay. And now the other guy's insurance company was suing him.
第二天，那位司机，一个俄罗斯人，让他去一个修理厂。他和老板，可能是他的朋友，给他看了车另一侧的一个巨大凹痕，并说损失是 2,000 谢克尔。出租车司机拒绝支付。现在那个人的保险公司正在起诉他。
"Don't worry, it'll be OK", I tell him, in the hope that my words will make him stop talking for a minute. "How will it be OK?" he complains. "They're going to screw me. Those bastards are going to squeeze the money out of me. You see how unfair it is? Five days I haven't slept. Do you get what I'm saying?"
“别担心，会没事的，”我告诉他，希望我的话能让他停止说话片刻。“怎么会没事？”他抱怨道。“他们会敲诈我。那些混蛋会从我身上榨钱。你看到它有多不公平吗？五天没睡了。你明白我在说什么吗？”
"Stop thinking about it", I suggest. Try thinking about other things in your life, happy things." "I can't", the cab driver groans and grimaces. "I just can't." "Then stop talking to me about it", I say. "Keep on thinking and suffering, but just don't tell me about it anymore, OK?"
“别再想它了，”我建议。“试着想想你生活中的其他事情，快乐的事情。”“我做不到，”出租车司机呻吟并做鬼脸。“我就是做不到。”“那别再跟我说这件事了，”我说。“继续想，继续受苦，但只是别再告诉我了，好吗？”
"It's not the money", the taxi driver continues, "believe me. Yesterday, I went with my son to the graves of the Tzaddikim. We bought blessings for 1,800 shekels, and I didn't mind paying. It's the injustice that gets me." "Shut up", I say, finally losing it. "Just shut up for a minute!"
“这不是钱的事，”出租车司机继续说道，“相信我。昨天，我和我儿子去了圣人墓。我们买了价值 1,800 谢克尔的祝福，我不介意支付。是不公正让我抓狂。”“闭嘴，”我说，最终失控了。“只要闭嘴一分钟！”
"What are you yelling for?" the cab driver asked, insulted. "I'm an old man. It's not nice." "I'm yelling because my father is going to die if they don't cut his tongue out of his mouth", I continued to yell. "I'm yelling because my wife is in the hospital after a miscarriage."
“你为什么大喊大叫？”出租车司机问，受到侮辱。“我是个老人。这不礼貌。”“我大喊大叫是因为如果他们不切掉他的舌头，我父亲就会死，”我继续吼道。“我大喊大叫是因为我的妻子在流产后住院了。”
The driver is silent for the first time since I got into his taxi. And now I'm suddenly the one who can't stop the stream of words. "Let's make a deal", I say. "Get me to an ATM, and I'll take out 2,000 shekels and give it to you. In exchange, it'll be your father who has to have his tongue removed and your wife who's lying in a hospital bed getting a blood transfusion after a miscarriage."
司机在我上车后第一次沉默了。现在突然是我无法停止话语流。 “做个交易，”我说。“带我去自动取款机，我取 2,000 谢克尔给你。作为交换，必须切除舌头的是你父亲，躺在医院病床上在流产后接受输血的是你的妻子。”
The driver is still silent. And now so am I. I feel a little uncomfortable for having shouted at him, but not uncomfortable enough to apologize. To avoid his eyes, I look out the window. We missed the exit to Tel Aviv. I tell him that, politely. Or I shouted, angrily. I don't recall anymore.
司机依然沉默。现在我也一样。因为对他大喊大叫，我觉得有点不舒服，但没到不舒服到要道歉的地步。为了避开他的眼睛，我看向窗外。我们错过了去特拉维夫的出口。我礼貌地告诉他。或者我愤怒地大喊。我不记得了。
He tells me not to worry. He doesn't really know the way, but in a minute he'll find out. A few seconds later, he parks in the right lane of the highway after managing to convince another driver to stop. He starts to get out of the taxi to ask for directions to Tel Aviv. "You'll kill us both", I tell him. "You can't stop here." "30 years I'm a cabbie", he tosses back at me as he gets out of the taxi. "30 years and not one accident."
他告诉我别担心。他其实不知道路，但过一会儿他会找到的。几秒钟后，他设法说服另一位司机停车后，把车停在高速公路的右车道上。他开始下出租车问去特拉维夫的路。“你会害死我们俩的，”我告诉他。“你不能停在这儿。”“做了 30 年出租车司机，”他下车时抛给我。“30 年了，没出过一次事故。”
Alone in the cab, I can feel the tears rising. I don't want to cry. I don't want to feel sorry for myself. I want to be positive, like my dad. My wife is fine now, and we already have a wonderful son.
独自在车里，我能感觉到眼泪在涌出。我不想哭。我不想为自己感到难过。我想像我父亲一样积极。我的妻子现在很好，我们已经有一个很棒的儿子。
My dad survived the Holocaust. That's not just the half full glass, it's an overflowing one. I don't want to cry, not in this taxi, not next to this driver that I yelled at. The tears are welling up and will soon begin to flow.
我父亲在大屠杀中幸存下来。那不仅仅是半满的杯子，那是溢出的杯子。我不想哭，不能在这辆出租车里，不能在那个我对他大吼大叫的司机旁边。眼泪正在涌出，很快就会开始流下。
Suddenly, I hear a crashing boom and the sound of windows breaking. The world around me shatters. A silver car veers across the next lane, completely smashed. The taxi moves too, but not on the ground. It floats above it, towards the concrete wall on the side of the road. After it hits, there's another bang. Another car must have hit the taxi.
突然，我听到一声撞击声和窗户破碎的声音。我周围的世界破碎了。一辆银色轿车转向穿过下一条车道，完全被砸碎了。出租车也动了，但不是在地上。它漂浮在它上面，向路边的混凝土墙。在它撞击之后，还有另一声巨响。另一辆车一定撞上了出租车。
A second before the ambulance drives away, they load the taxi driver into it. Deep in my heart, I was hoping they'd send us in separate ambulances, but it just wasn't my day. The driver, looking revitalized and happy, lights a cigarette. The paramedic wears a yarmulke and tells me I was very lucky. An accident like that with no deaths is a miracle.
救护车开走前的一秒，他们把出租车司机装了进去。内心深处，我希望他们用不同的救护车送我们，但这根本不是我的一天。司机看起来容光焕发、快乐地抽着烟。护理人员戴着基帕，告诉我我很幸运。那样的事故没有死亡真是个奇迹。
"The minute you're discharged from the hospital", he says, "you should run to the nearest synagogue and give thanks for still being alive." My cell phone rings. It's my dad. He's only calling ask how my day at the university was and whether the little one is asleep yet.
“你出院的那一分钟，”他说，“你应该跑去最近的犹太会堂感谢仍然活着。”我的手机响了。是我父亲。他打电话只是问我在大学的一天怎么样，小家伙睡了没有。
I tell him that the little one is sleeping, and my day at the university was great. And Shira, my wife, is fine, too. She just stepped into the shower. "What's that noise?" he asks. "An ambulance siren", I tell him and try to sound casual. "One just passed by in the street."
我告诉他小家伙在睡觉，我在大学的一天很棒。Shira，我的妻子，也很好。她刚进淋浴间。“那是什么噪音？”他问。“救护车警报器，”我告诉他，并试图听起来随便。“有一个刚刚在街上经过。”
Once, five years ago when I was in Sicily with my wife and son, I called my dad to ask how he was. He said everything was fine. In the background, a voice on a loudspeaker was calling a Dr. Schulman to the operating room. "Where are you?" I asked. "In the supermarket", my dad said without a moment's hesitation. "They're announcing on the loudspeaker that someone lost her purse." He sounded so convincing when he said that, so confident and happy.
有一次，五年前我和妻子儿子在西西里时，我打电话给父亲问他怎么样。他说一切都好。背景中，扩音器里的声音在召唤 Schulman 医生去手术室。“你在哪？”我问。“在超市，”我父亲不假思索地说。“他们在扩音器里宣布有人丢了钱包。”他说那话时听起来那么令人信服，那么自信和快乐。
"Why are you crying?" my dad asks now from the other side of the line. I force myself to smile, hoping he can sense it, too. "It's nothing", I say, as the ambulance stops next to the emergency ward and the paramedic slams the ambulance doors open. "Really, it's nothing."
“你为什么哭？”我父亲现在在电话那边问。我强迫自己微笑，希望他也能感觉到。“没什么，”我说，当救护车停在急诊室旁边，护理人员猛地打开救护车门时。“真的，没什么。”
Michael Chernus, reading a story by Etkar Keret. Etkar's most recent collection of stories is called Fly Already. And just this week, the new TV series that he wrote and directed with his wife Shira Geffen, Middleman, premiered on television in France and Germany. I have seen this show. It is amazing. I hope it gets to the United States soon.
Michael Chernus，朗读 Etkar Keret 的故事。Etkar 最近的短篇小说集名为《Fly Already》。就在本周，他和妻子 Shira Geffen 编剧和导演的新电视连续剧《Middleman》在法国和德国的电视上首映。我看过这个节目。它很棒。我希望它能尽快进入美国。
Our program was produced today by one of our managing editors, Sarah Abdurrahman and Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put our show together today includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Chris Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
我们的节目今天由我们的管理编辑之一 Sarah Abdurrahman 和 Aviva DeKornfeld 制作。今天制作我们节目的人包括 Bim Adewunmi、Elna Baker、Emanuele Berry、Susan Burton、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Noor Gill、Damien Graef、Lina Misitzis、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp、Lilly Sullivan、Chris Swetala、Matt Tierney 和 Julie Whitaker。
Our other managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Harrison Nesbitt, Alexi Horowitz-Ghazi, and Eileen Berry.
我们的另一位管理编辑是 Diane Wu。我们的执行编辑是 David Kestenbaum。今天特别感谢 Harrison Nesbitt、Alexi Horowitz-Ghazi 和 Eileen Berry。
I first read about Damon Linker's column in The Week, by reading Andrew Sullivan's column in New York Magazine. Our website thisamericanlife.org where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free during your lockdown or your commute to your essential job.
我第一次读到 Damon Linker 在《The Week》上的专栏，是通过读 Andrew Sullivan 在《纽约杂志》上的专栏。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以在封锁期间或通勤到基本工作岗位时免费流媒体播放我们超过 700 集的档案。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, before he began his distinguished career in public broadcasting, Torey worked in an ice cream truck. But, I don't know, man, there were certain basics of the job I think he never got used to. Every single stop, he would greet the customers crowding around the window exactly the same way.
《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人 Mr. Torey Malatia。你知道，在他开始公共广播事业之前，Torey 在一辆冰淇淋车上工作。但是，我不知道，伙计，我认为他从未习惯工作中的某些基本知识。每一次停下来，他都会向挤在窗边聚集的顾客打招呼，方式完全相同。
You're just children. I didn't expect you to be children.
你们只是孩子。我没想到你们会是孩子。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是 Ira Glass，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。